parme première journée mondiale contre
la peine de mort 60 villes se mobilisent
aujourd'hui 30 novembre date à laquelle
en 1786 la peine de mort a été abolie
par un état pour la première fois
c'était le duché de toscane les idées
abolitionniste ont progressé ces
dernières décennies mais 86 pays
appliquent encore la peine capitale
frédéric monteil images d'un autre temps
juin 1939
la dernière exécution publique en france
aujourd'hui la peine de mort est abolie
depuis 1977
mais le châtiment suprême est encore
répandue dans 86 pays
selon certaines estimations 4700
condamnés ont été tués l'an dernier dans
le monde record de la peine capitale
la chine avec environ 3500 exécution
suivi de près par les états unis
terry mccook a été accusé du meurtre de
sa voisine est condamné à mort au texas
innocenté par un test adn il a échappé
au pire après des années de lutte
si vous appartenez à une minorité si
vous n'avez pas d'argent pour payer un
avocat vous avez toutes les chances
d'être condamné à mort aucune personne
riche et blanche ne se trouve dans les
couloirs de la mort au texas pendant ma
détention j'ai vu sur quarante et un
homme et une femme être exécutée
aujourd'hui des hommes comme kerry max
cook des associations comme amnistie
internationale se mobilise pour faire de
ce samedi la première journée mondiale
contre la peine de mort